we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is our friend juan who sometimes
refers to himself as the troll man
if he's asking the question he asks in
this voicemail genuinely
it's actually a good one let's discuss
hey david what's up it's juan i have a
question
why are you against or discredited
anecdote
a lot of decisions that i make in my
life are based on my experience my
anecdotal experience am i to ignore that
and just guide myself by what 99 of the
population goes through
that doesn't make any sense
anecdotes are important
and people make decisions based on their
experience
why why
should anyone discredit
or not guide themselves by their own
global experience yeah so this is it's
this is a great question my anecdotes
are my experience why wouldn't i guide
myself by that
the first thing is you have to be able
to distinguish when we say something is
anecdotal
we're sort of by definition saying that
it is not representative or it's not a
large enough sample size
guiding oneself by their own experience
is great for example if you've driven to
work the same way every day for a month
and it's taken you no less than 25 20
minutes and no more than 35 minutes okay
it is logical to say based on my
experience
i probably will never take
under 20 minutes to get to work or more
than 35 in 95 of the times i drive to
work but that's not really anecdotal
that's actually a large enough sample
size to be able to say
an anecdote would be you move to a new
city and you say i start a new job
tomorrow today's sunday i'm going to
drive to work to see how long it takes
but it's la
and the oscars are going on that day and
so traffic is crazy and it takes you 90
minutes to do the drive on sunday to
then say well my experience is the drive
took 90 minutes i'm going to plan on 90
minutes tomorrow monday morning
that would be incorrectly making
decisions based on anecdotal experience
personal experience can be anecdotal or
it can be comprehensive anecdotes aren't
useful for causation okay
i have a headache
i eat five lemons and the headache goes
away and i go lemons must cause it must
must prevent headaches well headaches
usually go away on their own anyway that
one anecdote doesn't tell me that lemons
cure my headache even though it was my
quote experience it was an anecdotal
experience you really need a
double-blind randomized controlled trial
to look at that
and then you also have to consider that
headache is a condition we have a
regression to the mean where it
typically goes away and people go i no
longer have a headache even if you do
nothing anecdotes aren't controlled
they're not representative they're often
a sample size of one or two or you know
they're also not systematically
collected lots of people told me when
they get a cold they make a tea from the
leaves of dostoyevsky novels
they drink it and the cold goes away
within a couple days well it's a biased
group of people who tried something
weird they might be particularly
interested in telling others about it
whereas lots of people get a cold and
they go there's no treatment for it i'm
gonna wait three to five days and then
it'll be gone and they don't mention to
you hey you know what nothing i tried
worked so the cold eventually went away
so these are not systematically
collected anecdotes so
i hope that what i'm saying is clear
but when juan says what's wrong with
anecdotes anecdotes or my experience
experience can be anecdotal or it can be
comprehensive i'll give you another
example
every day what i do this show
from only my own experience from only my
own experience i'm able to judge
how long is it going to take me to
produce the show today okay and the you
know the show itself is 55 minutes
and then we do a 15-minute bonus show
and whatever that's an hour and 10
minutes but i know there's breaks and
whatever so i go listen i need just
under two hours to produce the show
it's only based on what i've experienced
but it's not anecdotal in the sense that
it's a comprehensive experience over
years of doing this and it is of
predictive value it's different than if
you say hey david today
you're hosting some other show
and i do it once and it takes me four
hours and i go i guess this show takes
four hours to produce well no it was
your first time doing it you're not
experienced at doing it yet that's the
difference i hope that it's clear we
have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about gavin newsom
2024 we are there's polling now about
gavin newsom 2024. we are going to talk
about gas prices going down in the
united states 21 days in a row
this must be joe biden's doing right i
mean if it's joe biden's fault that the
gas prices went up it must be joe
biden's fault that the gas prices went
down or not we will discuss and we will
also give you the latest with basketball
player brittany geiner griner sorry who
has written a letter to joe biden
asking for help all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com